hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem kontakt hier am
sonntag auf einem kanal bei
wunderschönem wetter super tag heute
sind keine ahnung wieviel gerade auf
jeden fall viel zu heißt deswegen bin
ich froh dass ich jetzt drin bin und
dass jetzt endlich aufnehmen kann hier
und zwar habe ich will wieder ein thema
ausgesucht was mir sehr oft in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde
als ich so gefragt haben ja was wollt
ihr denn für themen haben bei der
kontakt soll ja nicht immer so sein dass
ich die ganze woche zusammenfasst und
einfach mal ein kurzes spiel hat
videomacher sondern es soll natürlich
auch um themen gehen die ihr euch
wünscht und die könnt ihr noch weiterhin
unten in die kommentare reinschreiben
also das könnte jetzt machen wenn ihr
wollt dass ich wegen treten schreibt das
jetzt in die kommentare das thema heute
behandelt zehn dinge die ich vor meinem
tod machen möchte
einige die verwaltung machen möchte da
muss ich allerdings sagen dass die zehn
dinge die ich jetzt nacheinander sagen
werde nicht die reihenfolge ist sondern
das ist einfach zehn willkürliche dinge
sind ich noch von meinem tod gerne
erledigen möchte aber jetzt nicht
irgendwie eine prioritäten ordnung
darstellen oder so ich würde echt
unglaublich gerne irgendwann mal mit
delfinen schwimmen da stelle ich mir
sogar vor wenn man einfach mit delfinen
so mehr ist einfach frei und mit tieren
quasi nichts
dementsprechend interagiert dass man
halt mit denen zusammen schwimmen kann
und in deren elemente ist weil sonst
wenn man mit tieren ist dann ist man
immer auf der erde umgehen und irgendwas
anderes mit hunden oder so aber wenn man
dann quasi mit den delfinen in ihrem
element ist weiß nicht stemmen das voll
cool wenn man so mit delfinen schwimmen
oder auch irgendwie mit mit schildkröten
irgendwie so schild oder so weiß nicht
irgendwie somit mit ihren zeit
verbringen somit berechtigt exotischen
tieren das finde ich cool
dann will ich auch richtig gerne die
welt einfach von oben sehen also sei es
irgendwie einem heftig wie noch nie
luftballon geflogen glaube ich also
sagen einem luftballon ganz ganz weit
oben
oder noch besser einfach
fallschirmspringen wenn man dann
wirklich so durch die wolken durch oder
bei klarer sicht quasi die komplette
nicht die komplette welt aber sehr sehr
viel von oben sieht weil ich stelle mir
dann immer so freut sich dass man bei
google maps wenn ich so was von oben
anguckt dann denke ich mir sogar wenn
ich falsche springen sieht es genauso
aus
und keine ahnung dass wenn ich auf jeden
fall richtig cool ich habe zwar respekt
davor fallschirm zu springen und quasi
man selbst ist ja nicht an
verantwortlich dafür was passiert
sondern das ist ja der winter alle
anderen verhältnisse also
theoretisch also ich hab da schon angst
vor aber ich würde gern mal machen dass
man in die welt von oben sieht nicht so
wie beim bungee-jumping wenn man 100
meter am boden ist einfach runter
springen da siehst ja nix das ist
adrenalin kick aber wirklich irgendwann
mal so die welt von oben sehen das wäre
echt cool
dann stelle ich mir auch richtig cool
vor wenn man einfach mit seinem truck
oder mit zum buggy oder keine ahnung mit
irgendwas was hinter der ladefläche halt
dran machen kann einfach nach draußen zu
fahren in die wildnis und unterm
sternenhimmel zu schlafen also einfach
so betten reinlegen und kissen und alles
mögliche über zu essen mitnehmen grill
und dann einfach so daliegen und einfach
so in die sterne schauen das finde ich
cool dann möchte ich etwas machen was
denke ich jeder von euch machen will uns
möchte ich eine komplette nacht lang die
ganze schule für mich haben 30 kann
machen was ich will
das wäre so witzig glaube ich will erst
mal alle klassen gehen die schüler
einfach rausschmeißen einfach irgendwie
ein tisch legen die tafel schmeißen dann
irgendwie auch im fußball mit dem oder
eine bowlingkugel noch besser und
einfach die ganzen fenster einschlagen
alles weiß nicht ich finde das total
witzig wenn man so einfach mal so eine
nacht sondern es muss ich mal die schule
sein es kann ja auch irgendwie weiß
nicht die schulbibliothek sein das kann
nur ein media-markt sein oder so dann
einfach das eigene haus wenn man das
einfach mal so komplett kaputt machen
dürfte und es wird quasi keine
konsequenzen mit sich ziehen
das wäre echt richtig cool damit ist
einfach eine ganz ganz so gut oder so
gegen die an irgendwas aus lassen könnte
und man hat keine konsequenzen das wäre
sogar ich würde auch richtig gern später
wenn ich irgendwann mein sohn hat also
ich wünsche mir auf jeden fall ein kind
und brauchen sohn mit diesem sohn hat so
richtig viel scheiße machen also richtig
viel schwachsinn einfach so keine ahnung
was irgendwie klingen streichen einfach
weglaufen sondern richtig klein dann
richtig klein weise nicht so einen
kleinen luca ein vorhaben das ist bei so
wird sie jetzt eine sache die ich glaube
ich bald schon machen werde und zwar
nicht einfach mal ganz weit weg gefallen
also ich habe jetzt mein abi hinter mir
die ganze schule und ich habe jetzt zeit
bis zu meinem studium
das tor vorbeigeht das studium los und
dann bis dahin möchte ich auf jeden fall
einfach mal irgendwie sind nicht an
nichts von travelworks so dass sich auch
die arbeiter sondern das ja mal
wegfahren von der ganzen welt hier und
also nicht von der welt aber aus
deutschland weg fahren irgendwohin sei
es italien ist kann auch irgendwie weil
sie nicht nur seeland sein oder
irgendwie sowas irgendwohin irland keine
ahnung wo es wirklich ruhig es kommen
einfach entspannen kann dann gehe ich
einfach so alleine wirklich alleine
irgendwo hinfahren das wäre echt richtig
cool finden dann möchte ich mir später
wenn ich umgezogen bin eine riesige
instagram band machen also es gibt zu
viele bilder die ich täglich auf
instagram eigenen account ist übrigens
auch in der beschreibung verlinkt da
könnte immer vorbei schauen aber ich
lage wirklich so viele bilder auf
instagram von irgendwelchen leuten die
echt coole sachen fotografieren sei es
irgendwie ganz zugewachsen wald am
morgen oder noch so nebel es mit dem
coolen filter drauf oder sei es einfach
wo welche mit dem fahrrad bungee jump
also mit dem fahrrad fallschirmspringer
aus mit dem pfarrer rampf und dann mit
dem fallschirm dann das fahrrad fallen
lassen und so da gibt es richtig richtig
coole bilder auf instagram man nicht
unbedingt meine bilder eine instagram
wand auch von mir und freunden aber auch
so einfach bilder die mir einfach
gefallen von instagram dann möchte ich
das denn alles so quadrate
diese könnten quadrate sind nehmen
sondern dann so eine komplette wand
damit voll
so weisen nicht zwei quadratmeter locker
damit und das finde ich echt richtig
cool wenn ich aus meinem zimmer später
hätte an eine sache was ich noch nie
wirklich hatte und zwar möchte ich ein
buch lesen was mich auch mal richtig
fesselt das einzige buch und meinem
ganzen leben was ich bisher gelesen habe
wir sind drei bücher sind erebos das
habe ich ja schon mal darüber gesprochen
der schwarm und harry potter teil 4 oder
irgendwie so oder ja ich glaube aber
dass und das sind die einzigen bücher
die mich gefesselt haben und die ich
bisher gelesen hat weil sonst alle
anderen bücher die ich gelesen habe habe
ich nach 20 seiten aufgehört und ich als
richtig cool wenn ich mal so ein buch
lesen würde
was mich wirklich fesselt wo ich nicht
sage boah keinen bock weiter zu lesen
sowie einer schule sondern wirklich ein
buch was richtig geil ist dann möchte
ich unglaublich gern mal früh morgens
mit dem boot einfach auf dem see
rausfahren und dann einfach mal da
sonntag lang bleiben also wirklich
einfach mit dem boot rausfahren dann
irgendwie den sonnenaufgang angucken so
wenn das wenn der see noch so niedlich
ist dann einfach auf dem boot stellen
und einfach nichts mitnehmen so nur ich
selbst irgendwie an
eine auf sein boot und einfach
nachdenken weiß nicht dass es ziemlich
gut den uns hört sich vielleicht komisch
an aber was ich form hin
das ist ein bisschen widersprüchlich
irgendwie sind die dinge die ich vor
meinem tod machen möchte aber ich möchte
ein zehnter stelle steht ich möchte
fröhlich sterben also ich möchte nicht
irgendwie wenn ich die diagnose bekommen
okay du hast eine krankheit und du
stehst in drei monaten aber wenn wir dir
die und die medikamente geben und demasi
und die chemotherapie und die munition
zu lange im alltäglichen wetter nimmt
die ganzen tabletten dann stehst du erst
in fünf monaten würde ich sagen nein
bock drauf stehe ständig lieber zwei
monate früher und macht vorher noch mein
ding und er lebt einfach dinge die ich
bei sonderthema therapie nicht erleben
würde also bei der chemotherapie würde
ich dann oder wegen einer therapie
dichter machen müsste werde der natur
würde ich dann halt wirklich ganz nach
ähnlichen geräten hängen und könnt mich
nicht mehr kontrollieren und alles und
wäre von diesen geräten und ärzten
abhängig sondern ich möchte einfach
wirklich wenn das soweit ist möchte ich
einfach entweder direkt sterben oder
halt noch so lange mein ding machen bis
ich auf natürlichem weg sterbe und nicht
durch irgendwelche versorgungs
gerätschaften dahin ihrem leben gehalten
werden das ist nicht mein
lebenserfüllung beim benzin tot sind auf
den tod zu gehen
ja das war schon wieder freunde mit dem
kontakt ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
wenn ihr themen habt über die ich lagern
soll oder die ich im kontakt behandeln
soll oder wenn ihr euch einfach mal dass
mein kontakt wünscht wo ich einfach
meine woche zusammen passte dann
schreibt sowie kommentare wenn es euch
gefallen habe ich nicht mag ich freuen
einen wunderschönen tag und tschüss